in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Gabe
and Megan are with us hey guys how's
life great
welcome welcome where do you all live
we're from Connersville Indiana which is
near I we're about halfway between
Indianapolis and Cincinnati okay cool
well good to have you in Nashville
thanks for joining us and you're here to
do your debt-free scream yes sir I love
it how much have you paid off
we've paid off thirty four thousand
eight hundred twenty-six dollars and
eight cents and we cash flowed an
additional twelve thousand on top of
that for what masters classes or Gabe my
medical bills okay and how long did it
take you to do this two and a half years
gotcha making what kind of range of
income during that time we started at
about 70 and then once they finished his
master's we bumped to about 82 and then
in January of 2015 we bumped back down
to 62 because I started staying home oh
very cool okay excellent what's your
master's in good IRA culture education
okay
very cool so you teach it your wife yeah
yeah I'm an Ag teacher and FFA advisor
okay perfect good for you fine so what
kind of debt was the thirty five
thousand oh my gosh we had a van payment
personal loans home equity loan or
credit card twice and medical bills
student loan them off okay all right but
$35,000 worth of debt and of course he's
got twelve thousand more to go on his
master's when you look up and realize
this two and a half years ago so what
happened what got you on fire well I I
started talking with a co-worker that
was listening her show and working the
plan and at first I wasn't really sold
but I started listening and started
listening podcast in the mornings before
school and after school and at night and
you kind of moved in there for a little
while and then when wife got a started
listening and she kind of got hooked and
then we started okay it took me a while
like I thought he had joined a call
initiative I mean it was in the morning
in the afternoon in the evening all the
time but here's a little too involved in
the podcast yeah I got you okay that
happens are addicting
it's a good addiction at least yeah so
uh he's doing all that and you just got
curious you want to know what all this
was about or what I'm not really sure I
finally picked up the Total Money
Makeover read it and said you know if
we're gonna do this we have to do it
together so we just kind of jumped in
and went from there
I waved the white flag and surrendered
okay I got it cool so that that time
then you said okay we got to do this
together then what was the first step
what did you do from there start reading
the book okay I finished it pretty quick
and then told him he needed to read it
he thought he knew since he listened to
the podcast he read it okay and actually
maybe sub 1 was easy for us because we
already had money in savings sure so
then we just started snowballing that
okay and just tore into it in two and a
half years yeah what was the hardest
part of the two and a half years for you
oh my gosh we didn't cut up our credit
card until January this year oh that's
why we had to pay it off twice oh um
because it's always kind of been you
figured out you have to learn some
things the hard way yeah it's gonna been
the thing that we relied on if something
came up
there's your emergency fund yeah because
we had never had anything saved but we
finally cut it out yeah when you ran my
after you paid it off and then you ran
that back up on it what were you buying
oh my gosh we got a new mattress okay it
wasn't an emergency
fell off the wagon in the middle of it
yeah absolutely all right and that added
to the balance that then you had to go
back in territory and hurt again yeah so
when you fall off the wagon like that
what caused you to how were you able to
get back on what what caused you to did
you just bounce back on and say okay
that's it or I mean did you like to take
a month off and then have to have a ream
eating kind of I mean how that happened
yeah we had hope back and just start
over I mean we were we were in debt
again and looked up and said what are we
doing we made some stupid decisions here
we just really started meeting regularly
and going through the budget and
focusing and listening to the podcast
and then I started listening morning
noon and it is right there okay so
really what happened was is the the the
mistake in the middle increased your
intensity to finish to the go on to the
finish line
absolutely now will you do it again we
go back in there again oh well you are
done yep they're gone okay very good
good for you guys congratulations
so um when you're when you're professor
Gabe and those students are in there and
they find out that Gabe doesn't borrow
money
yeah and he's debt free and they say how
did you do that what do you tell them
the secret to getting out of debt is
wait wait to get what you want you know
sacrifice some sacrifices and if you
really want something go work for it and
and yeah and actually right now we're in
class I talked about and our debts dumb
and how they never want to get into it
because I did with high school kids and
they're really looking at college and
and you know I'm only gonna pay $20,000
a year for college and I'm like guys you
got that money and they're like no
almost boom loans and and I just think
that's gonna really set you behind and
and try to talk to him about things like
that okay very cool very cool so I have
a plan and stay outta dad and what do
you all tell people when people ask you
how you got out of debt that what did
you guys do Meghan what's the secret to
what you did that we got on board
together together I was but when we came
together that was really helpful and
then honestly we've had so many people
tell us oh that's fine but I could never
do that or and you just have to commit
and and go and when you fall off the
wagon just I'm back on eventually and
it'll come you know it'll come out the
end yep okay perfect well good job y'all
it's an honor to meet you I'm proud of
you thank you very well done Gabe and
Meghan from Indianapolis and the kids
names are what it's cocora she's seven
hi Emma is six and Emmett is six okay
very cool
all right Cora and Emmett have they been
practicing oh yeah they're ready to go
all right Gabe and Meghan in
Indianapolis Indiana area $35,000 paid
off plus 12,000 paid towards his
master's in two and a half years making
70 to 80 to 262 count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream three two one
I love it I love it
I love it that is fun now you heard it
you heard the sound of a family tree
being changed the sound of a family tree
being changed hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the
dayroom 2 channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm panic so subscribe
and there's lots of videos about life
and money so while you're at it if you
want to check out a video then you can
check out how to do a monthly budget
it's one of the best videos out there
you